diese perfekten Mac and cheese brauchen
nur drei
Zutaten und sie sind in 10 Minuten
zubereitet und diese sind cheddderkäse
makaroni und Kondensmilch ungesüßt ganz
wichtig als erstes geben wir unsere
makaroni in einen Topf und ihr kauft am
besten diese leicht gebogenen dann geben
wir Wasser drauf und zwar so viel dass
die gerade bedeckt sind und bitte
schreibt mir nicht in die Kommentare
dass es vier Zutaten sind okay es sind
drei Zutaten einmal salzen und jetzt
kochen wir die Nudeln hier im Wasser
dass wir die Nudeln so Kochen hat einen
Vorteil und zwar bleibt die Stärke
Wasser und bindet später die Mac and
cheese zu einer cremigen Soße schaut
euch das mal an das Wasser ist vollends
verkocht und die Nudeln sind perfekt
gegart wir können ein bisschen runter
mit der Hitze und die Kondensmilch dazu
geben und jetzt geht's auch schon ab
denn jetzt kommt der Käse einfach oben
drüber und gib ihm rühren rühren rühren
der Käse ist geschmolzen und fertig sind
die perfekten Mac and cheese guckt euch
das einfach an es gibt keinen Grund Mac
and cheese anders zu machen deshalb big
shoutout an Kenji Lopez old von dem ist
das Rezept